hệ như sự mối mang tư duy ở ai.
A ai đang lên lỗi vào tục nóc nát cuộc sống từ các chúng ta làm việc,
giò tiếp đến ra quyết định mỗi ngày.
Tại Epiti, một trong những tập đoàn phía phòng trong bị cho nên viên tư duy ở ai phức sĩ.
Tư duy dên lựa khả năng hiểu, hợp tác và sáng tạo cùng A ai để giả tăng giả chi khác biệt.
A ai không chỉ là công nghệ, mà là người đồng hành giúp bối cả nhân làm việc thông minh hơn,
buối vẻ hơn và được tổ hiểu hơn.
Mà à, chờ liệu ảo gió Epiti phát triển là mình chứng gió nát trở điều đó,
bối tháng, Mà à, sử liệu hơn 5.000 lượt cho đội thứ hơn 18.000 viên,
tư việc chắc thử chiến sách đặt phòng học,
sinh y phép đến những tính năng đời thường điều bối vui hai cho chuyện chia sẻ.
Nhờ đó, nhân viên Epiti không chỉ tăng năng sức mà còn giảm các thằng và cảm thấy được quan tâm nhiều hơn.
Không chỉ là người bạn của nhân viên, Mà à còn là chở liệu cho lãnh đạo,
tự động phân tích sử liệu nghi việc, người cạnh báo cá nhân hoa khi có nhân sự chủ chốt nộp đơn giúp sánh nghiệp sử chân người tại kiếp thời.
Từ mai a đến hàng rật ấy ai ở trên lội bộ khác Như SkyChans,
ai viên chất hay các sẻ pháp ứng dụ ấy ai dài bài tỏng cho khách tháng.
Epiti đang tựng bước kiến tạo một thế hiện sự mang mạng mạng dình ấy ai phức,
người còn người và ai sau hành để cộng lũm giả trị lẫn nhau.